donnie wahlberg finally came on which is
great donnie was in uh kirk acevedo was
on there uh freddie joe our technical
advisor and a bunch of the cast and it
was basically mostly just fans just kind
of tuning in and again you know
i don't this is the first time i had
done any kind of zoom thing for better
brothers and
it was awesome you know
that matthew put this whole thing
together and to talk about the bravery
of these guys you know everyone who was
part of better brothers learned so much
because
we got to learn from from a generation
that didn't complain you know you know
here you are light infantry is supposed
to be going into normandy for a day or
two with with a leg bag that is probably
going to get blown off your leg that is
of course if you
survive the landing
and then to be there for you know almost
two months you know without
you know having a scrounge for food i'm
a scratch for weapons i haven't
scrounged for bullets grounds for
everything you know these guys learned
toughness at a young age and
you know
it it it
permeated through us like crazy you know
i remember when we were talking about
the other day
about four or five days into boot camp
it was almost like a mutiny because they
were just beating us up so bad which you
know i really enjoyed
uh really you enjoyed that
my dad was a sergeant in the army so i i
love pt i love you know the
let's go
i enjoy that stuff i really do
did you see other guys cry did anybody
get real yeah just get a lot of the
english guys couldn't you know because
the pro so pro american you know van
brothers are fantastic a lot of the
english guys who yes the sweetest nicest
guys are like what is what
what did we sign up for
uh and then tom hanks came in uh a
helicopter with his castaway beard and
hair
and gave us this speech as to why we owe
it to the men of easy company to work
our butts off to tell the truth because
they died for us and we're not for them
we wouldn't be speaking english right
now we wouldn't be the america that we
are right now we wouldn't be the great
country that we became we're not for
these men who gave their lives for us
michael after that everyone was just
like
yes sir was he emotional was he
emotional during that speech yeah
because it meant the world to him yeah
it wasn't just because it was his show
and you know he was the producer and
writer and director and you know he he
tom hanks is different from from just
about everyone else i've ever met
because he did it because it was the
right thing you know he flew from all
the way from hawaii just for a 20-minute
speech and then flew right back
who does that
you know you know it could have been a
video conference or something way back
then or something but no tom hank said
let's let's get on a plane and fly over
there and talk to the boys and make sure
they're on the right track and after
that you know we we tore it up